gibt es so eine schöne
postkartence und das stimmt doch es
langt für die Beachparty im Körper haben
sich am Strand lecken finde ich schön
von der anderen also
[Musik]
heute haben wir das ist Fleisch und
Bossard bodyshaming ist es großes Thema
dass man überhaupt nicht
so viel Pickel und trotzdem machen wir
ganz
titumsika
versprochen
einfach
sehr anders gesehen das dass die meisten
dass der Durchschnitt und denkt man eine
und bei mir selber
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber ich werde größer und ich
ich bin nicht klein ich bin ein
Konzentrat
ich finde das schon noch interessant
sich überlegen
und so bin ich und ich weiß gar nicht
anders schwer wenn ich sehr groß wäre
ich weiß es nicht sehr stark
untergegangen
wird andere du wirst schon die ganze
Zeit wieder von der Gesellschaft auf das
auf der Sieg gewesen sein genau
die positiven die Bewegung muss
ungeschminkt und dann ist das super die
positivity und eigentlich der Ursprung
von der positiven die Show ist ganz klar
politische Message in der Praxis
70er Jahre den USA
Diskriminierung
zeigen dass man viel weniger Tumore
gefunden hat diagnostiziert hätte jedes
einfach wieder dick ist und das wirklich
krass und und
die positiven Marketing sondern im
Ursprung politische Idee generell
aufgrund von österlichkeiten
diskriminiert werden
entsprechend weniger gut sein
schlechtere Job selber weniger weniger
lohnt werden weniger schnell beförder
zeigen das ist einfach nicht fair für
das muss man natürlich ganz viel
verändern können
soziale Medien wer latmerie wer
präsentiert man und das finde ich
natürlich gut dass man auch einfach so
Modus ist andere Zeit wo man also
genau
es geht der andere Arten von Schönheit
ja einerseits sind die ja also zum
Beispiel Susi Arbeit
Psychotherapeutin
Körper ideal Politisierung
damals mit betreut und massiert das ist
jetzt eigentlich Kosmetik herstellen sie
darf wo wo so Bodylotions und so
beworben hat aber unterschiedliche
diverse Körper verschiedene grosser
dicken schwarze und so weiter aber wenn
man jetzt
die ganze Germanys next Topmodel Staffel
mit diversity was passiert da eigentlich
glaube ich sie trotzdem wieder Reduktion
auf der Körper wenn du vocio diversity
ist
und die hätten auch genauso
Zeiten
nein das finde
Körperform aber das ist eigentlich finde
es unterlaufen Wahrheit diversity wo
immer auch Anerkennung dass der Körper
nicht so wichtig ist sondern wichtiger
Business das ist das noch nicht meine ja
aber dass der Körper nicht so wichtig
ist und nicht so wichtig für sie dass
ich was anderes anlegen das ist die new
travity also der Körper soll nicht
unbedingt positiv oder negativ sondern
auch nicht so wichtig sie es gibt schöne
so zieht Diagnose zum Beispiel vom
Grundsteuer Wissenschaftler Jörg
Scheller muss seit der Körper ist
unglaublich im Zentrum dieser Kultur
will will man erhöhten immer brauchen
das Werkzeug also die meisten von uns
ganz viele wo die entleistungs Jobcenter
Ganztag oben
Bau und der das wird er fast zu viel zu
einer Statussymbol fast zu meiner
Kunstwerk
Botschaft zum Zeigen hey also als
Verkörperung gefunden
aber das sind
Interesse schaffen oder so und ich finde
sobald der Körper nimmt funktioniert
also wenn man starke schwarze
jugendspital
nicht funktioniert und er mit ihr fahre
über längere Zeit macht
es anders Verhältnis zum Körper
dass die Sachen gönnt das ist nicht weh
tut und das ist schon
achtsamkeitsbewegung immer das
wichtigste Thema Tantal
hat dich gern
aber
schöne Postkarten
lecker finde schön
teilmaschine
wirst du viel stärker auf den Körper
reduziert und den Körper wird viel mehr
bewertet viel weniger die die
Neutralität wo vielleicht als manuell
du kennst das oder wo die Kamera sie
liegt
aus und das ist total Frechheit das
kriegt man eigentlich Tagesschau
Moderatorinnen und so wieder wie viel
Post hier zu jeder Kleider dazu das ist
total zwei verschiedene
Punkte immer über den Körper redet es
gibt der Philosoph Helmut Plessner das
ist ein anderer Block 700
Verhalten ist zu diesem eigenen Körper
nie es Selbstverständliches Zebra zum
Beispiel
entspricht sondern die Sachen sind immer
politisch gefahren und das glaube ich
mit leitfeindlichkeit zu viel zu tun
sondern sehr viel mehr kommerzialisiere
ich ja also quasi der Körper als Mangel
war sage ich jetzt mal ist natürlich so
wahnsinnige wiederum ein feministische
Punkte starke Frauen produziert wird
immer mehr
marginalisierten Gruppe gehört dass das
schon Punkt
Elisabeth Lechner vorkommt
österreichischer komponieren
homosexuell oder so genau und sie sagt
zum Beispiel
schlank schöne lange Haare wenn diese
auf Instagram abbildet mit Achselhaare
und recht modern und so die
feministische genau wenn es gleiche aber
ein übergewichtige
dunkelhütigen Frau macht dann ist es
abartig grusig wenn Sie den alte und
Achsel
interessant das ist nicht nur politisch
gefärbt sondern je nachdem
ganz anders
mitmachen und sich schminken und föhnen
und botoxet und was weiß ich noch alles
will nicht einfach
aber einige könnte sich leisten und zwar
will ich könnte sich Leistungen trotzdem
absolut und das ist Fragen Freiheit ähm
auch sehr interessieren
extrem schade also wenn du lügst bald
wieder etwas Schönheitsideal sind das
sind ziemlich Komfort und das ist eine
Hut das ist Gleichzeitigkeit das ist
einigermaßen Schlankheitsideal Muskel
beim anderen so klar ist das immer
kulturell überfahren Stichwort Rubens
und andere Schönheitsideal aber es geht
in Norden und ähm ich glaube das hätte
damit mit Erotik mit azig zu und ich
meine ich weiß nicht ob das so glauben
Zeit natürlich das hätte auch dass mir
jüngere Frauen und Männer tendenziell
hübscher finde das ist kein Zufall
sondern das hätte
Evolutionsgeschichte von Mensch irgend
das finde ich einfach so zur Kenntnisse
sondern einfach mal dass mir auch
biologisch gewesen und dir sind und wir
hätten erotische Bedürfnis und die sind
oft am Körper wir sind kein platonisch
leben die Seele aber da muss im Körper
besser
und ich würde von mir sagen ich habe
mich auf jeden Fall immer auch in meiner
verliert
also ich finde mit und das Sprache
deinen Staat für mich zumindestens eine
Erotik du hast eine Person sein und
unsympathie
schön findest auch wenn die Person
vielleicht nicht Norm schön ist Daten
wie sie sie lächelt
wie sie ist wie sie sich herzlich und
das ist halt oft weg ja
die ganze Staffel
genau trotzdem
durch und zeigt ganz klar eigentliche
Schere body positivitybewegung für ihn
ist es extrem übergewichtig sie ganz
klares Problem und der Seite es ist
gesundheitlich gefährlich es ist aber
auch so alles er findet weniger Freunde
er findet Platz im Restaurant er hat
kein Platz im Flugzeug
aufpassen
Youtuber sind gespannt auf eure
Kommentar andere Sprache zum Thema
Nacht übernommen und körperbrett und
Fleisch und bosshafen hat schon mal eine
über Schönheit diskutiert wenn du mir
Vorwand aktivieren danke